yeah hello and welcome to this video I
am the best it can be used opponent
night to D to who what do I play against
this
I know I should prevent Bishop c4 b3b
should be to the set up
I think I just go eat 6am but if it it's
been a while it's um quite comparable
set up to the one I'll employ against
Queen to see tune hmm okay quite happy
to trade why a bishop f6 maybe it
doesn't actually trade time again
tweenage voice completely pointless l50
that not do that just as night at three
okay well here a queen f6 doesn't white
help night h5 is no problem though we
can just continue to develop this should
be five maybe I don't know if that was a
nuisance or not k 2 95
yeah just back i guess i don't think i
have anything fancy available here
[Music]
yeah I should be generally ok here and
he doesn't have that many dangerous
ideas available I think some F form I
don't know that really Nets much
weekends awesome we can quite a bit yeah
i'm going to take care this is the
simplest way to do it and ok i don't
know Bishop d7 27 is not dangerous i
guess
yeah i thought we should have five is
good maybe i'm wrong 93 Bishop d3 is
what I was thinking but maybe there is a
technical drawback to that but I don't
see it really I don't see it I h5 i have
f 6 so why doesn't that work it is a bit
of a bit risky okay cannot move the
rukon f1 very likely he would trade
their queen takes and then should know
who gave three i take c 4 here what is
the thing nidec five maybe and they just
sell it could be dangerous it could be
really dangerous
[Music]
i am going to clean up a droopy 3m
probably not probably not maybe I have
to cover at 5pm okay
yeah I wanted to play and would be eight
came to get one and queen 85 we need
five in particular maybe he just takes
now and no oh oh nice one I didn't spot
that yeah let's see me maybe i get i get
some activity here with the rook coming
[Music]
you you almost always have some sort of
drawing chances in such a rogue ending
time morning
was hard to save a rooty force better or
not
maybe it was okay okay 74 that's so
quite decent
now you will remain a pawn up of course
till the end but still
probably d6 at the enter play with the a
pawn it takes a really long time here
okay I can still take when you pushes
this pawn and now I can actually take
the a porn oops draw offered quite
resigns I might have even take it item
but ok just resign now there was a clear
mouse clip the bit ridiculous to win
this position black um yeah I was always
worse not always but I it got worse let
sit him look them I was fairly happy and
around here yeah this is actually
something that i was thinking about and
there is a big problem so maybe age
three was it was was a problem he had a
bit and the knight Knight to g4 was
wasn't a good idea okay now i got this
trade it and this should be generally ok
yeah this is you can debate about that
but i felt i need to simplify a little
bit I don't think something bad was
going on here so this is all the key
moment I think this didn't work all
night h5 looks like plus a million that
surprises me why I will clean be seven
or something wow wow okay I only saw
this and here I didn't see a great move
because I felt this looks pretty awful
movie eight saves me okay I can have it
at least that the right hands down
even though it was for the wrong reasons
6q g3 we had made in one move he had
made into one hahahahahahaha oh god that
is not a check only one oh wow and you
just recaptured yeah now wondered why is
that so bad what is wrong with water cup
oh my I just screwed up the recording
area oh my god okay any one of them
luckiest oops luckiest wins and oh yeah
I should have decent drawing chances
here so this this in route d3 okay that
is still very good for him not sure if
i'm losing what's very Larkin yeah I've
I'm completely stunned oh my god made in
one okay thanks for watching